o lado pessoal de quem fala é o dark
existe muito menos mais um eu hoje nós
vamos mandar coisas com a nossa presença
coisas como esta aqui no brusque
empunhou uma pilha que inclusive eu acho
que já me peguei méxico já não lembro do
resultado então vamos fazer até mesmo
uma bola bem mal anti-estresse meu
espaço no clube
o brinquedo 50 cds tipnis em cima do
outro e eu tenho aqui pessoal a coisa
que eu mais tenho curiosidade para ver
que um boneco supostamente isso é que é
indiscutível então vamos ver se consegue
resistir à nossa imprensa do evento tudo
lá é tudo vuitton existem mas não sei
que nesse pessoal portanto vejo até o
fim e se forem novos aqui no canal e
león e deixei muito lá que me inscrevi
porque isso ajuda muito que o canal eo
fixo luis méxico e agora só vamos lá a
ver uma coisa com a nossa presença para
lá então sua primeira coisa que nós
vamos tentar esmagar vai ser o nosso
fresquinho depois do bloco podem vir
obstáculo ele cheio
olha aí mas sim eu vou deixar bem assim
mas posso mandar o nosso cuidou para
aproximar e produção a próxima a ir para
lá pessoal do piso está mesmo a tocar
olha isso também tem seus problemas
presa vez um espanhol em 3 2 11
eu já comecei a jogar pouco vai explodir
vai explodir sob um sol pra baixo mas
proibidos cumpro meus contratos porém
que traz não está pronta há muito está
muito do nosso que está muito duro mas
ei out new energy finance para isso
isso parece uma cola ou pra chorar o
peso toque pessoal vá ter alguma
resistência agora tem que fazer muita
força para prepararem o substituto
uma instituição que possui que continua
a ser corredor por isso não fico num
pela experiência mas vamos ver o que
realmente aconteceu aqui dentro o que é
conteúdo entrou aqui dentro
ok já saiu tá muito mais maleável é
porque eu fico todo então dá pra ganhar
muito melhor e dá pra roubar player o
estranho
sua tampa então toda presente imprensa
contra bola de estresse em 321 bairro é
portar 28 lado do pivô rasho rio
eu sei eu estou sentindo ainda há muito
por fazer muita força já existir um som
play e agora já não tava está muito
apertada quer votar o peso igual está
bom é muito forte e eu não conhecia o
rigoroso nada desse não estava à espera
vamos lá próxima a getjar é próximos
dias vai ser o nosso carrinho do
brinquedo isso vai explodir fácil porque
é um clássico em duro mas por ora o
mercadinho de brinquedo contra pressa e
en 321 vai começar a cortar folhas ou
excluir quem já está perdido nenhum jogo
star wars já quebrou já já quebrou e
espero que vocês estejam coisa que não
vai está outra vez com mais força
meu deus mas não gosta já tô cansado
brasil
calma o o oe vai punir
veja só como é o nosso carinho
op a contratar no máximo comportado mas
já está fazendo muita força presença já
não consegue mais pessoal 20 toneladas
em cima de um carrinho que voltar ao
peso e vejam só pessoal
este aqui é o nosso carrinho ficou assim
completamente esmagado foi quem foi
aplicada à força e dá pra ver né pessoal
próximos é uma vida completamente normal
uma pilha alcalina acho que ele
exatamente isso que pode ser um
experimento tóxico portanto vamos tentar
manter afastada desse piso e agora vou
lançar uma pergunta profissão acho que
foi um salto
não mas ela não é ela não é oficializado
acho que sua filha vai pegar fogo
sim acho que não vai pegar fogo
vai ser muito tóxico esta experiência
pressa quanto de pilha alcalina agora só
falta eu nem querem aparecer no vídeo já
começaram os melhores olhei lá embaixo
do altar com o socorro
meu deus isso faz bonita eu tô com medo
voltou a brincar a brincar por lei por
aí
o que é isso o que será
é um produto tóxico que maneira se for
law já tem um escudo anti impacto será
de radioatividade
será que o plano é assim ó cair por ela
continuar a pagar 31 vai mais poder
aprender muito aqui mas atenção para o
céu
eu aqui falei sobre uma taxa de maio
vamos conseguir pagar a pena toda a bola
só para o peso e olha como ficou a nossa
pilha olha é isso nem quero tirar o
esperto porque deve ser muito tóxico
mesmo então eu vou guardar isto aqui no
paninho juntamente como equipe ir para
como liquidado no plano por isso é um
equipes terrestres como assim no futuro
no pano eu sou obrigado mole vamos
mandar o estudo ainda faltam para o leão
que faz um som um software
agora é só colocar aqui bem no centro
pensei muito e vou lá presa mesmo
silêncio em 321 raptar vamos ver o que
vai acontecer
vou tentar fazer o máximo que for
possível
está muito complicado talvez existentes
se ver
ontem tinham sacar o seu só tá fazendo
explodir a qualquer momento aqui vou pra
mais eu vou tentar trocar com muita
opção série está muito apertado tá muito
ah não dá já não deixe mais dependo só
não deixe a água é impossível já não é
mais só quer voltar o peso e vamos ver
como é que os nossos cinemas 4 3 2 1
nada sou o primeiro escudo e trouxe um
pouco duros mas o resto está tudo novo
funciona tudo a posto só vocês ganharam
uma presença até agora foi um dos
objetos foi abalada expressa o interesse
vamos lá o próximo e ao último objeto
para a revista o boneco instrutivo é
conhecido como street a ahlstrom e isso
é que é muito resistente porque eu tenho
uma espécie de material estranho dentro
deu esse é o nosso neco
ou sou top já é muito bom muito
satisfatório e vocês podem ficar à
vontade deste neco olha é muito louco
olha só perdeu bem elástico fechar com
muita força e não aguenta
ela só vamos colocar o nosso homem super
existentes na nossa imprensa e eu vou
colocar assim bem na zona do peito que é
onde tem mais pressão eo tem mais massa
e agora é só para preço agora a e
pessoal comenta embaixo vocês acham que
vai acontecer
acham que faz poder coloca em estado de
fusão se acham que não vai acontecer
nada porém este navio assim você ver que
foi votar na explosão e no nada eu voto
na explosão se bem que o vasco nilton
acima de 50 e 51
vocês só vão saber se continuará entre o
vídeo tal como eu então vamos lá pra
nossa presença lá cansa muito espaço que
vai ficar bem um chato disse que não
então eu vou fazer com esse preço versus
homem elástico indestrutível em 3 2 1
imagine uma prensa com espírito da nossa
barriga e isso acontecia isso voltou a
ficar muito grande
cansado apertar mas vamos fazer o máximo
força agora
ok eu acho que a nossa presença já não
tem mais peso já está no máximo
muito preocupado está muito apertada
porque ele entrou toda por dentro
vamos soltar o ar
corro boneco culo aqui boneco lúculo no
ferro olha só clicado nela um buraco na
barriga não condicionada não
condicionando no pac i ta rijo nem abril
no bairro jockey então vamos tentar
outra coisa eu vou colocá lo assim e
para lá eu só está bem apertado eu acho
que sim vai funcionar se vai ter
qualquer resultado
olha só o cara deu mais força é para
quem não tem os raptos com cocô ok já
está no máximo vamos soltar o peso
meu deus será que não aconteceu nada eu
não acredito tem que acontecer alguma
coisa agora aconteceu agora sim só os
parentes ou teve uma coisa bem bem
estranha à lei nem sempre que eu acho
que abriu a usina que eu tenho por
dentro da lei
sua oficialmente a nossa presença ganhou
ao homem destrutível porque abriu o q2
buracos e agora vamos a um x-ato prever
o que tem dentro ora lá o uê melo e mel
acho que mesmo só vejam só eu acho que é
meu mesmo eu nem quero ficar por aqui
mas já saí eu acho olha aí muito
estranho essa intoxicação é porque não
era vendido em brinquedo netão a partida
isso não é tóxico é só usar esse pessoal
é muito estranho eu acho que isso é a
resina mesmo assim está comprovada
aí agora não sai do governo olha só do
lado eu vou deixar ele aqui mas só
espero que vocês tenham gostado aqui
neste vídeo com a imprensa e de
esperança escreveu assim em cima de um
erro olha aí quase que eles terão a
seguinte agora jovem esteve aqui uma
defesa com a empresa mas a espera tem um
status quiserem ter mais filhos com a
imprensa comenta embaixo também essa
imprensa e assim vocês querem ver mais
deixei muito claro que destruiu se não
for inscrito no canal escuna é novo e já
sabem amanhã provavelmente vai ser um
jogo de tudo ou portanto fique atento ao
canal e é isso fique bem até a próxima